unsere vision wie gesagt diese jeden
motor der im linken stiftung
einzubringen und da sind für uns
natürlich die multiplikatoren als
veränderungs botschafter einen ganz
zentralen spieler eine ganz wichtige
rolle
das heißt ich will mit einem lama man
uns im programmteil als mentoren
multiplizieren diesen gedanken
unterliegen zb auf fakultätsrat zu gehen
ich habe auch wirklich los die
diskussion unter lehrern an um diesen
gedanken voran zu kommen
sie führen eine oft projekt im rahmen
dieses jahres eine wie zum beispiel im
bereich gelegen
der ältere herr thele wird und wir haben
heute auch weitere multiplikatoren hier
gerne doppelkopf den ich da hinten stand
und auch kein schlüssel er später noch
kommen fragt ersten berichten werde wir
fahren in den multiplikatoren nach durch
reiter deckung nicht nur im bereich
lehre und begeistern sondern vor allem
auch im bereich das networking und
austausch untereinander und unterstützen
für eine zeitschrift gezielten coach ich
ihnen diese projekte im ort zu machen an
den start zu bringen und nachhaltig zu
gestalten
uns ist ganz wichtig dass es vor einem
absicht sein wird das heißt wir arbeiten
zum beispiel mit interviews mit
erfahrenen multiplikatoren im mittel
jahren dass sie mitunter aussehen
sie sind herzlich eingeladen sich
vielleicht mit zu nehmen um das
sozusagen nicht in der schublade
verschwinden zu lassen sondern auch
öffentlich zu machen und ganz zentraler
bestandteil unserer programme sind
natürlich die unterstützung durch die
hilfskräfte die wir heute auch mit dabei
haben zum teil ohne die es gar nicht
glücklich wäre
und gestern haben wir in den feierlichen
abschluss mit dem zertifikat genau und
damit geht es aber auch weiterhin
motiviert vor ihn als aluminium die
gleichung weitere auch botschafter hier
innerhalb der jungen menschen und auch
darüber hinaus
warum empfehle ich ihnen das meine ich
auch immer wieder an stücke aus dem
projekt stehen der multiplikatoren
bringen werden
ich möchte ich hier mit einem total
einsteiger ist weiterhin genug zeit
trifft den gefunden haben
das heißt wer etwas lernt kann es noch
verlernen
doch einmal verstanden kann man es nicht
endlich verstehen erst einmal das
gelernte verstanden hat kann ihnen es
nicht nur wieder drin sondern auch zum
neuen verknüpfen oder selbstständig
verändern und das ist uns ganz wichtig
wenn wir über lernen und trainer
sprechen dann ist es natürlich so dass
wir verschiedene lernen zu vergleichen
kann
sicher können wir darüber sprechen
etwas einfach auswendig lernt und wieder
gibt aber man möchte ja eigentlich diese
hören lernen zugegeben erreichen spricht
ein tieferes verständnis bei den
studierenden transfer ja das heißt das
was man mit veranstaltungen lernen und
mit dem wissen aus anderen
veranstaltungen verknüpfen zu können im
alltag anwenden zu können in der
forschung an den strand und die in
tieferes verständnis zu entwickeln
und deshalb ist unsere botschaft ihres
vortrags sie heute auch digitale
lernmedien können das lernen
unterstützen aber phw einfach der
einsatz digitaler lernen beginnt mit
macht noch keinen erfolg unser ziel ist
es natürlich die sich gezielt
einzusetzen um zum beispiel motivation
zu fordern und eben dieses tiefere
verständnis und da möchte ich mit einer
kleinen geschichte starten um auf dieses
verständnis des lärms während einzugeben
es ist eine kinder um vielleicht
kenntnis der ein oder andere unternehmen
auf ihre mini fisch ist fisch und die
geschichte zu folgen und so einrichtung
ein forschungs und befreundete kennen
sich schon wird kaum wartezeiten und der
frau später dann natürlich erwachsenen
geht irgendwann land total verrückt in
den teich zu fisch fängt er an zu
erzählen dass england anders erlebt hat
und erzählt die er gesehen hat und der
versucht sich natürlich vorstellen dass
der vorstand gibt also wenn sie tiere
die wir in fischform schneider geflügel
mit den fehlern in den flügeln und der
vorstand bereitet das eher kühl gesehen
hat und der frau zu stellen
diese bögen ausgehen also die fressen
gras haben schwarze flecken und
steinhöfer menschen die die ag hat sich
auf zwei beinen gehen und bekleidet sind
und auch der frisch versteht eben oder
menschen das was er sich darunter
vorstellt und was dann ist der
kindergeschichte eigentlich total zu
sehen kann ist das 20 des
konstruktivismus also dass sie lernen
funktioniert lernen es nämlich nicht
dass wir als dozenten und so wissen eins
zu eins in die köpfe der studenten
pflanzen und dann wenn ich hier
diese runde an
kann ich sicher sein wenn sie alle
später in die kaffeepause starten
das geht ja von irgendetwas anderes
mitgenommen hat im vortrag wie heute
halten nämlich auf basis dessen was sie
vor gerichten auf jeden vorerfahrungen
auf ihrem vorwissen und das ist einfach
total zentral das ich im hinterkopf zu
behalten man kann dieses prinzip des
konstruktivismus sowie lernen
funktioniert nämlich optimal auch für
seine lehre verbänden und entsprechend
zu gestalten
und dann gibt das prinzipiell gefahren
und helena marion weike diesen gedanken
des konstruktivismus aufgreifen und
versuchen darauf passierte firmen zu
geben wie meine lehre optimieren kann
und dieses lernen eben optimal zu
gestalten
das ist zum einen die sicherheit der
lernumgebung das eis um eine
bestmögliche traktion des gesichts und
einem tiefer übrigens verständnis zu
fahren es ist eigentlich von vorteil
die lernumgebung so lange wie möglich in
der umgebung ist in der das wissen
spielte angewandt werden sollen also
optimal kann man so was natürlich in
ausbildungsberufen sehen wo bereits am
arbeitsplatz das ist ihm gelernt wird
aber es ist auch möglich innerhalb der
hochschule
allen natürlichen teil der medien und da
möchte ich zwei beispiele nennen aus
unserem kompletten einmal aus dem
bereich fahrzeuge sinken da gibt es zum
beispiel das team unsere erste
mannschaft deutlich dass um das lernen
von anatomie und da gibt es mittlerweile
viele computer tische in denen sozusagen
eine digitale mensch eingebaut ist
auf dem bildschirm und dieser mensch
lässt sich der anatomischen gegen
entscheiden im knochen versus muss so
dass das so sagen für die studierenden
endlich wirklich praktisch in der
vorlesung auf den darsteller ist wie die
anderen turniere funktioniert und die
einzelnen bestandteile zusammenwirken
ein anderes beispiel auch für technik
beziehen
doch das wenn frau kursen auto vor
einigen jahren die eine e learning
umgebung gestaltet haben nur die
studenten zum beispiel herztöne
verbunden sich innerhalb der umgebung
anhören konnten und so gehört sich das
anderes herz gesund ist oder auch in der
hund zum beispiel einem herz grad also
durch digitale wege werden sich uns ganz
neue möglichkeiten die lernumgebung
mit indien klassenraum zu bringen und
schon so sieht ihr zu gestalten dass die
studenten möglichst viel davon mitnehmen
können
das zweite prinzip besteht authentizität
das heißt in dieser weise findet lernen
dann standen die studierenden einen
praktischen bezug zu ihrem wissen zu
ihrem alltag haben und das kann man
natürlich machen indem man in der
vorlesung oder im seminar die
studierenden um einige beispiele bittet
und das ganze wird natürlich noch viel
einfacher mit der digitalisierung denken
zum beispiel die über claassens systeme
abzufragen
technisch schreiben das heißt reduzieren
dem brand hier vorne auf dem laptop live
dass der studierenden zum beispiel im
smartphone und an beispielen eingeben
ohne auch hier in einem projekt als ein
jahr schützen und die später auch mal
präsentieren werden
die ihre lernbedingungen in der
archäologie von stücken für stück
lebendige stadt
verlassen um möglichst sagen die welt in
richtung nebendran zu sagen das dritte
prinzip ist der raum für eigene
aktivität ich glaube dass es uns allen
als irgendein relativ klar sich
lediglich bewiesen zu lassen
erzeugt in der regel keine vertiefte
wissen das sind wir dann fertig bin
versuchen mit diesem wissen zu arbeiten
und die digitalisierung bietet auch hier
natürlich die möglichkeit eigene
aktivität wird rein zu können zum
beispiel oder feedback systeme in großen
gewerkschaften oder weiß aber auch
beispielsweise über meine umwelt ist das
konzept der jakob wirklich geht darum
vorstellen wird und die frauen so quasi
umgekehrt wird ein so die
wissensvermittlung zum beispiel griff
hat karas videos im voraus stattfindet
und dann die vorlesungen dazu genutzt
wird gruppen arbeiten zur gestaltung
kritischen zu machen um die eigenen
aktivitäten zu sagen und das wissen und
das verständnis zu vertiefen und es wird
im prinzip können anderen forschern und
politikern perspektiven also leicht
verständlichen steht vor allem auch der
angriff suchen
aus verschiedenen wegen zu beachten da
haben wir gestern in der
podiumsdiskussion beispielsweise
komplette ihren tieren konzipiert aus
verschiedenen winkeln dingen und sachen
machen sie in der medizin biologie und
medizin zusammenzubringen lernen und zu
gestalten diskussionsforen virtuelle um
den austausch zwischen den verschiedenen
apotheken zu fahren und das militärische
wissen eben aus verschiedenen
perspektiven zu beleuchten und mit alten
prinzipien können uns dann sozusagen
dahingleiten
die digitalen medien ob so einsetzen
können das lernen von beitragen
somit ist natürlich nur ein verständnis
und lehren und lernen wichtig sondern
ein es ist alles prinzip sagen die
psychologen immer die motivation ohne
dass der motivierte studenten haben
können wir uns dann sag ich mal
vorsichtig gesagt hier vorne aber kaum
erklären erfolg ist mit duncan möglich
jedoch steht sozusagen jeden teil in der
sache geben
und wie schaffen wir jetzt also
motivation bei unseren studenten zu
erzeugen
warum greifen um ihre motivation könnte
mich so gut verständlich bis 20
warum keine kommunikation ob man
zusätzlich heraus weil digitale des
lernens haben wir
der problems diskussion gehört oft
strukturell noch nicht geregelt ist
selbst unter nicht jetzt ist ein teil
der chance dass sich die zeit ich bin
wörtlich flexibel ich bin auch
unabhängig vom berg personen das waren
was natürlich gerade künftige
generationen der studierenden identität
ist die kennen das ist das der grund sie
wollte dass es gewirkt aber auch in
diesem wird das risiko natürlich auch zu
hoher flexibilität jetzt gekommen es zum
beschluss vorgelegt das risiko der
beliebigkeit
das heißt es ist eigentlich kann muss
aber nicht
und wir freuen uns motivation der faktor
der das überflüssig kann muss aber nicht
in einem möglichen möchten ist das macht
das eben in ihrer arbeit mit digitalen
runtergekommen ist gefragt
gerne mal gelten deshalb ist es auch
schon mal zusammen agitator durchgesetzt
ein überblick haben
das ist die zentrale geschichte
es gibt auch sehr viele studien
sitzungen die genaueste sagen und zwar
was an der rotation es gibt ja
verschiedene motivationen heraus
gegriffen das ist die intention
motivation und die studien besagen dass
es hier unten die verweise dass gerade
für die inhalte frage der fragen die du
offensichtlich motivation gefördert das
ist so was wie hier sind erklärt uns
verständigen
die informationsverwaltung die
verarbeitungs und ausdauer
das ist der zentrale geschichte
was hast du dir unter den trainings
motivation selbst in osteologie von
diesen dreien und wir da immer sehr
gerne haben die designer das motivation
aber nicht in dem bereich transactions
war extrem sich und ging durch die
presse weiter nicht schlecht dass es
gibt natürlich auch studierende extra zu
motivieren bedeutet der wert der
aufgaben bearbeitung der wert der nicht
im internet beim messe kommen über esta
der kauf über zum beispiel ganz klar ist
natürlich bei der studierenden über
noten
das heißt wir loslegen der wert kommt
von externen prozent das ist wichtig und
das bildungssystem kommt auch schon text
kann ich rege dafür noten funktioniert
natürlich aber funktioniert lange nicht
so gut wie in trance situation weil da
der werte im index
ich befasse mich mit etwas weiß für mich
gemacht und sind das belohnungssystem
das fast noch wichtiger ist bis ins
training
ich habe spaß und freude dabei also das
was ich immer wahnsinnig der die kinder
lernen kinder leiden unheimlich die
anlagen mit spaß und freude und spieler
nicht
das ist so der weg wie wir letztlich ein
triple wirklich gedacht wir wären jetzt
funktionieren
deswegen scheint mir der mir geraten
dass zusätzliche motivation
jetzt ist aber natürlich sowie habe ich
die leistung zugriff
ich kann natürlich nicht machen dass ich
gerade jetzt interessiert ich kann ich
im kopf schütteln ich kann nichts machen
dass der spaß und freude hat also das
muss jetzt der nachwuchs nicht zu sagen
kann ist den rahmen der möglichkeiten
das ist idealerweise passieren kann
das ist wichtig weil manchmal merkt man
die veränderung also lieber nicht
also entweder sich diese motivation
verlegt beim städtchen meine
verantwortung ist der name internet
jetzt ist es so dass wir irgend wenn wir
diese interesse motivation nicht vorher
eine extrem schlechte präsentation haben
allerdings kann ich auch in der breite
und zwar ist der gradmesser wie ich in
extremistische motivation zumindest
annähernd im internet zwischen
überführen kann und der karte selbst
recht hat das ist wirklich so dass das
auto umgebaut habe ich das gefühl dass
dies nicht stimmen kann
da gibt es drei stufen wird so der ex
tun habe wenn wir über sie lernen
bleiben und dabei spielt die bewertung
durch noten lernen für prüfungen
verstehen
optisch immer ist ganz leicht motivation
geht bei externer lerne für gute noten
okay aber natürlich das wissen ist viel
weniger tief das wissen sind schnell
vergessen dass wissentlich ausländern
bei der zweiten stufe weiter irgendwo
hier sind stufe da ist ein bisschen mehr
von einer psychischen rheinbergs
gekommen mitgefühl
allerdings weist das land vermeiden also
im bereich drogen ich möchte dabei dass
ich mich schnell es war nicht schlecht
im rücken gehabt dass ich schlecht dann
stimmt etwas zählt schon jetzt viel mehr
dass er redet gerne noch ein bisschen
mehr anders würde ich war schon so eine
gefühls gegner dabei das problem an der
stelle ist dass im zweifelsfall lässt
ein schild gehäuft auch sogar zu
schlechterem ergebnis geführt dass die
erste stufe ich kriege angst und
gewissen einiges gelernt so schlecht und
mit angst ist auf den text ein test
schlecht zu starten und das kommt denn
ich denke kommt bedeutet in dem fall
welche misserfolg habt dann bin ich in
meinem alter ist das sez gewesen
also werden ideal zu dieser stufe zu
kommen wo es wieder den patienten
integriert ist
dafür müssen
es ist wirklich wichtig gute laune haben
ich möchte den großstädter haben ich
weiß dass das was ich jetzt lernen dort
anwender ist für sich dass dortmund gut
im beruf zu sagen und schon kracht dass
dieses möchte damit sind wir relativ nah
an der endlichen motivation
davon ist der sprung der muss natürlich
von den leuten weitergegangen werden ist
das natürlich verliert wie komme ich an
zu welcher er gegen den zu grunde
auf was muss ich achten beide gitarre
und nehmen daher erst modelle basics
wenig wahrscheinlich keines von ihnen
tiere hinein gehen
sozial eingebunden gemeldet stand alone
nicht gefehlt verlässliches soziales
tiere
das heißt dass man wirklich nicht
vernachlässigen was in gruppen aus nach
sozialem lernen bedeutet die kooperation
dass mir diese mental gruppe lernte aber
auf der dozent auch der wird natürlich
zum vorbild der kannst du dir mehr für
den ich lerne weil ich in werkstatt von
weise ist eine kompetenz teufel weiß
teufel gegeben hast du mittendrin
nächste verdi kommentaren kompetenz das
wichtig ist nicht so gefasst dass ich
wirklich das ist nicht haben dass ich
bis man sie bekommt einen besonderen
kompetenz ist gefasst dass ich mich
persönlich kompetent fühle die aufgaben
die mir gestellt werde sogar das heißt
mit den lehrern der name muss klar sein
das ist bei den fahrern gesprochen und
er nicht ausschließen publizieren
ich muss diesen wiederum und dann
schluss ich des österreich wenn mir der
damen und fordern eingegeben wird fühle
ich nicht kompetent will ich mich
unterstützt habt das gefühl ich kann das
was auf uns zukommt leisten und
regelmäßiges feedback ist auch super
wichtig in dem bericht wirklich mit
kompetenz werden zu lassen dass
kompetenzen was letztes die autonomie
dass man wieder ganz klar die
selbstbestimmung
das hat was zu tun jetzt wo habe ich den
wagen gespannt
und ich habe eigentlich recht viele
wahlmöglichkeiten als dozenten die
möglichkeiten dass die studierenden zu
geben
man kann oft weh realistischen
verschiedenen aufgaben
man kann es an dem lernen zu ermöglichen
man kann also es ist ganz anders klingt
alles weg sagt in seminaren thema das
jetzt zu hören als wir sagen mir den sie
mir wichtig dass wir heute folgendes
wir können uns über den unter dem bild
es gibt die 2
welches nur rollen nicht liegen wenn wir
heute nicht wieder schnell sein ist für
mich da geht es doch irgendwas was mir
wichtig dann werde ich gefragt da habe
ich mitbestimmungsrecht bin ich mit
meiner meinung richtig da habe ich die
möglichkeit fragen zu stellen dass ein
dach befördert
jetzt ist es klar fischer sah natürlich
untersucht angesehen und es war heute
wichtig die digitale händlern deswegen
wollen wir ihnen ein paar projekte
vorstellen also die partizipieren
leistung unserer erfahrungen als unsere
multiplikatoren bringen alles was ich
sage die projekte sicher wenn sie
absteigen
auf der gegenseite noch mal alles war
sika ländern aber auch in sich gehabt
muss ich sagen da möchte ich anknüpfen
sehr gerne länger man diese skizzen
anschauen und dann unsere gruppen
entsteht dort finden sie noch mal die
ansprechraten und einer mütze holte den
controller als botschafter der guten er
nicht wirklich gern bereit mit jeder
noch meines vereins operativen ist ganz
wichtig und was man sonst unsere
multiplikatoren mitnehmen was wir machen
regelmäßige kontrollen nach den ersten
jahr und da kann es ist schon ein ganz
wichtig dass ich in der planung zurück
nehmen euch diese basics als die ersten
beiden ich befürchte den austausch zudem
wichtige stakeholder bis in das dt
werden dies vielleicht auch mit anwenden
die noch in einem fahrzeug mit denen
mich nicht verletzen möchte und es sind
die studierenden das heißt wenn mich von
anfang an dem motorrad in dem ich sie
einiges sehen der nicht eben zu befragen
und nach anforderungen ist eine ganz
andere motivation hat dieses irgendwie
hässlich machen auch zu benutzen
gestern der polemische diskussion kann
zb in aussicht dass jetzt fast übel
akzeptieren meinte ernst erhält jetzt
das ist aber auch oft mithin gescheitert
weil es eben nicht gedacht nicht fahren
das heißt man spart sich viel arbeit wie
möglich anfangen
wir haben einen welt zum beispiel dass
die sprachwissenschaften und frau dr
doch der stress der fahrer hat und
die haben die hose gemacht der sich
eigentlich schade was ist dann bei uns
der fall authentisch und peter was
gibt's dann stand das leben kehrt die
ziehung und bedenken haben wirklich
manipuliert sondern auch als bedarf in
kontakt und haben daraus dann neue
konzept denn die gesetze neue innovative
bedarfsgerechte recht ähnlich sind damit
hätten in der verlängerung und haben
damit wirklich freue mich dass in
formaten wie funktionieren weil ich
schon gemacht haben und was erst
eingerichtet nur der ist er nachfragen
wenn ich nach ein bisschen an getötet
das was ich gerade gesagt habe
alles was natürlich wissen vertieft alle
etwas vorbereitet ist geprüft wird gerne
genommen aber jetzt richtet das fenster
dann wichtiger als sex
die herrn sich also mehr endlich klar zu
machen das ist mein herz um über gerade
vorgegangen
das an was will ich überhaupt ja
nachricht die lernziel ist in der
geleistet haben wir auch die erste
podiumsdiskussion beim hoffest ein
grüner aus dem schlichten
kunstwissenschaften der gesagt präsent
wäre ist mittlerweile sehr strukturiert
digitale lehre sehr unstrukturiert jetzt
kann ich den vorteil nutzen diese
methoden verbindung und sehen dass das
funktioniert weder selbst lehre und
überziehe auf digitale zb mit tanzen
lernt elementares zurückzufahren
ich weiß wo ich hin will daraus leite
ich habe ich dann gemerkt dass ich am
schluss testen und bislang ich denke und
das gegenüber virtuelle lernen auf das
musst du dich einfach es funktionieren
da gibt es eben wirklich erfahrung in
grenzen da das hat schon erwähnt wurde
die einbindung der studierenden das
projekt ist noch folgen
frage frau und ihre tochter schütze dann
hört sie noch mehr dazu und das werk ist
eine optische gestaltung das am namen
wirklich richtig feine studierenden
leben virtuelle mittlerweile die sind da
sehr viel gewohnt die haben hohes niveau
anheben wie schaust du eine lehre aus
wie ist die gestaltung und daher ist
eine drop out rate sehr schnell daran
merken denn lernen auch digital ist es
sehr nahe ist optisch nicht also auch
dass es das mit der händler muss ich
greife japanische hinaus wir haben keine
frage kommen sagt wir uns intensiver
nochmal ganze fragen also wichtig ist so
dass relativ auf veranstaltungen das war
wirklich zusammen starten projekte hinzu
auch aus den sprachwissenschaften die
sich überlebt haben
ich muss die leute abgrund und verhalten
der haben möchte muss sich selbst
gegeben habe ich darum mich zu viel
erwarten fest der test habe ich nicht
erwarten dass sie mit allen methoden ist
ich muss die ab ich musste ihnen
wirklich erzählt was ich mache ich muss
die hemmschwelle senken
dies sind zb in der jimmy wales frau
doktor raum und herr professor peters
sind dann gegen eine gerne lernen
studierende in die veranstaltung
gegangen haben ihre methoden mit
konkreten beispielen dienst und hast da
hat 24 dazu gedacht ist sich damit
wirklich auseinandersetzen weil es eben
nicht pflichtveranstaltungen sind die
digitale hausen zurück zur veranstaltung
ich darf natürlich nicht vergessen dass
ich der ansprechpartner bleibe als
dozent das kann ich auch digital wichtig
ist gemeinsames ziel das geht so
verhalten ein projekt oder frau und groß
aus dem sprachwissenschaft und die haben
ein präsenzseminar gehabt und haben das
dann über fertigen digital und zwar
gemeinsam mit den studierenden die haben
gemeinsam danken und digitalen buch
daraus gemacht dass das vielleicht
demnächst gearbeitet haben und an dem
dann in die nächste generation weiter
arbeitet und was uns ganz wichtig
ist ihre präsenz der kombination von
digital und von analogen klassische mit
dabei haben wir heute auch über das werk
von irgendwo her doch keiner glaubt
inverter klassen inverted glas um 30
grad die meisten sofort auf digital oder
dort vor links auf mitschnitte aber auch
durch andere digitale angebote bis heute
vorbereitet in ihrer präsenz phase geht
es dann gelungen das leben über das
wissen gesprochen wird es verknüpft wird
es vertieft wird immer gegeben haben
dann will man nämlich nochmals für die
förderung von ort und somit bringt auf
den drei versuche ich mich auch zu
fassen wenn sie noch nicht zu einer
vertiefung der guten stunde auch in
afrika und natürlich der fragerunde zur
verfügung hat er alles richtig ist
natürlich die chance zu nehmen auf die
herren zu hören die gemeinsam mit den
studierenden gegen 1 situation und das
funktioniert natürlich nicht nur
interessant sondern auch in der digital
geringere auswahl
das muss ich auch viel einfacher
wir alle sind natürlich zum beispiel
ermutigen der anderen gegend so
gestaltet haben studierende
wahlmöglichkeiten zwischen aufgaben
texten videos doch mal zeitliche
flexibilität jetzt viel mehr geleistet
natürlich die dir digitalen wäre und
auch die möglichkeit des fundes und
schwarze freude über ansprechenden
lernumgebungen gewünscht hätte
möglichkeit überhaupt blogs wie
beispielsweise verwendet wie möglich im
digitalbereich und bestimmte das
kompetenz erleben braucht das können wir
natürlich auch ein zwischen einwerben
gerade im digitalen bereich zum beispiel
über feedback systeme in der freunde
sangen schon zu erfassen ob die dennoch
mit dabei auch das tempo zu hoch ist ob
wir die davor irgendwo untergetaucht
dadurch lassen sich zu ihren zwischen
den anforderungen und gleichzeitig den
was die studierenden offenen bringen und
damit letztlich auch egal dass ich fünf
wochen über multi perspektiven
verschiedene fachrichtungen mit 1
die brücke zu schlagen auch über
verschiedene veranstaltungen genau das
wir haben dann versucht im bereich cross
greifen vor allem auf unsere
multiplikatoren der windindustrie
marktwirtschaft man den sehr
grundlegende bedürfnisse der motivation
auch bei studenten zu fördern und damit
sind wir mit unseren vortrag eigentlich
noch schon am ende und freuen uns vor
allem darauf mit ihnen zu vertiefen oder
sie für erfahrungen gemacht habe
mit dem verständnis von lernen und im
verbund mit digitaler mehrere bekommt
der motivation jetzt dafür weichen
[Applaus]